and finally new rule now that the Trump
phenomenon seems to have peaked
Americans must ask themselves why why
for so long was there one set of rules
for everyone who's ever run for
president and then suddenly a completely
new set for this Donald Trump person
because when it comes to lowering the
bar he really raised the bar so
it's been a year in a day since Donald
Trump descended on an escalator to
announce he was running for president
and since then he's just kept on
descending so let me take you back in
time to the pre Trump era and show you
what people used to think was a
monstrous political gaffe here's al gore
and Bush the first each doing something
at a debate that the country found to be
beyond the pale there's differences we
have a question right here
yes how has a national debt shocking
isn't it sighing and looking at your
watch to show such blatant disrespect
for our sacred democracy then there's
this guy at a debate bragging about his
dick he referred to my hands if they're
small something else must be small I
guarantee you there's no problem I
guarantee
what if Bush had done that read my lips
six and a half inches or take the
sensitive issue of race there was a
firestorm back in 92 when Ross Perot
said to a black audience and I don't
have to tell you who gets hurt first
when this sort of thing happens to it
you give people day oh my god he said
you people smother him with the AIDS
quilt George Allen was a rising star in
2006 and then his career was over when
he said this pillow here over here with
the yellow shirt macaca or whatever his
name is did you hear it did you hear
what everybody he said macaca whatever
the [ __ ] that is Trump tweets more
racist [ __ ] than that before lunch he
retweets white supremacy began his
campaign by calling an entire minority
group rapists he says our black
president faked his birth and might be
working with Isis he did this look at my
african-american over here look at him
that's not worse than you people
and what about basic old dumbness I seem
to remember dan quayle being pronounced
unfit for office dumb because he
misspelled potato and Sarah Palin's
brief flirtation with respectability
came crashing down when she could not
name what news sources she read all of
them any of them that have been in front
of me over all these years what Trump
doesn't even pretend he can read he just
hears things I'm hearing a lot of people
are saying this is his favorite news so
he hears things it could be from a
passing mental patient could be the
voices in his own head and when he does
when he does read it's the National
Enquirer and he refers to it as the
paper oh I'm sorry I'm not being fair he
does have one other news source all I
know is what's on the Internet
right me too I get my news from pornhub
no wonder he once said I love the poorly
educated John McCain and Bob Dole both
veterans but war does things to a man
both were accused of being too angry too
angry to be president after all Bob Dole
once said this
and Senator Dole is there anything you'd
like to say to the vice president yeah
stop lying about my record what a raving
lunatic but this is okay I don't know
what I said ah
I don't remember yeah what about that
Obama once just compared his poor
bowling skills to the Special Olympics
cut to the apology tour but we're good
with this uh I don't know what I said
ah and finally the ultimate third rail
insulting the military Obama got endless
[ __ ] for once saluting with coffee in
his hand violating an ancient military
rule dating to never
but Trump can say John McCain isn't a
war hero if Hillary said that they'd be
burning pantsuits in effigy